this is for cars ah he took the
consultants fees and ran you know sure
consultants can get away with that I
mean it seems like a pretty shady job to
begin with consulting yeah I mean I'll
say I'm in our harness all I'm doing
right now I just take my friend tall
John when I go get a car yeah he acts
kind of intimidating did he think that
certain ago sir how about we go $300 off
the price or my friends gonna pick you
up
I love it if that works like you know
just Seminole y'all help change some of
these numbers the guy bought a car for
cowboy had more boots why would you ever
buy a car from someone in the area in a
boot why are you putting all this thing
all this I got it he at all yeah
see what we're talking about yeah they
ever want anything that is Canadian
that's out
yeah I'm not dealing with two pieces of
papers the two checks let's first you
Kate she paid in twice they want 1,400
hundred and ten dollars should I give it
to him he was so convincing everything
he said I was like ah he's right that
guy he showed up with a gaseum Vanilla
creamer you can't buy one of these Doug
you're buying a 50 pack of these and
you're not buying a 50 pack of manila
folders unless you're somebody who does
business
[Music]